oh my god YouTube it has been a while he
been on tool for a little bit doing the
comedy grind - stand up comedy grind so
if you know I can't be a city I said
what's up look at me
I'm pretty again oh do me hey what's
going on YouTube
I missed you since the last time I've
seen you I've been trying to get my life
together
i'ma go this year to be able to touch my
toes and see my penis over my belly
button yep we laugh but it hurts now
there's a movie out there that I have a
love/hate relationship with and for some
reason I keep coming back to this over
and over and you know what movie I'm
talking about this movie was a huge part
of my childhood and they came out on
June 18th in 2001 and yes I'm talking
about The Fast and the Furious Fast and
Furious if you guys know this is one of
those movies that you will always hate
on the outside but you love on the
inside that movie is like the cinema
version of McDonald's you won't hate it
on the outside but you're still gonna
eat it [ __ ] but uh but Baba we fetes
[ __ ] in case y'all don't know I'm a huge
fan of Fast and Furious
even though I don't want to be you guys
remember when that when we first came
out instantly everybody wanted a rice
rocket and if you didn't know how to
drive stick you were a [ __ ] I happen to
be one of those [ __ ] and because that
movie everybody wanted a Toyota Supra
yes that's right go get me a high
because of that will be imported Asian
cars even the Honda Civic started to
become the [ __ ] and you know because of
this movie every ghetto Asian
[ __ ] started adding stupid [ __ ]
to that car that had nothing to do with
NXP what's the spoiler for long spoiler
and 45 [ __ ] panel no doesn't qgj 75
horde paulo but the [ __ ] are you talking
about scotch-tape 70 horsepower god
dammit now drop here's no matter how
much you love this movie you have to
admit this [ __ ] has gotten ridiculous
and listen I understand that once you
move past the trilogy mark it becomes
harder and harder to think of new [ __ ]
for the movie but god damn there is [ __ ]
in this film that no other film can get
away with just because it's fast and
furious for example how the [ __ ] can
anyone fly through a windshield of a car
and come out without
single scratch and my whole life I never
see somebody skin so Brazilian to glass
and a gun which you got bulletproof
lotion [ __ ] in fact six Vin Diesel flew
out of a car window and his shirt still
had the folds on it out of the box you
got a demonic gas t-shirt as my father
would say that's a dabbler did you
notice that throughout every single
movie that full without Phil were a
single tank top given in that one part
in faster than what he got married he
somehow managed to wear linen pants with
a white tank top what that blows closet
look like a wardrobe for the
domestically abused throughout this
whole movie there is a reoccurring theme
and it is about family but if you said
the word family one more [ __ ] time in
that movie I was gonna [ __ ] take a
bullet to the tip of my dick just put
listen we get it I'll have friends
I've got fan what the [ __ ] are you doing
a dog sir I was just talking myself
really uh people gotta use the [ __ ]
back in the [ __ ] out you don't have
friends you have family but is that the
only thing you don't want to say get it
dunk ask me that couple quick you don't
turn your back on them what the [ __ ]
that's not what I asked at all and let's
talk about fast seven for a moment
because there was a lot of [ __ ] that
just didn't make sense
explain to me while you're looking for
something in order to find someone when
he already comes after you in case you
didn't notice he wasn't hiding Jason
Statham was the villain in this movie
and that [ __ ] was teleporting all over
the place like a [ __ ] Dragon Ball Z
character anybody know how he does it
why are you so [ __ ] rich but he only
shows up with a gun and a [ __ ] tank
somehow no [ __ ] joke what I just said
was literally the whole movie and I
don't even understand how Letty just
happen to have amnesia after she happens
to roll away from a car explosion the
other quart of the movie is just Vin
Diesel just trying to convince his girl
that she knows who the [ __ ] she is Dom I
don't remember but I still love you cuz
you're family but I had sex with like 15
other guys but you still family
I have gonorrhea but you still family
cuz I still got [ __ ] why and let's not
even go back to the sixth movie how they
took down a military tank
Vin Diesel flew 50
feet caught his girlfriend in mid-air
smashed into a car and his shirt was
perfectly fine I'd always like a pg-13
movie but still man you got to give me
like a bloody nose or something how
could you be in the car explosion get
hit in the face with a let pipe and
still have nothing happen to you I
dropped the iPad on my face yesterday I
got [ __ ] dogs but even despite all the
[ __ ] I still gotta say I love it oh you
gets me right here I don't know maybe
something's wrong with me I just see
everything wrong with it but I still
enjoy on the sick I'm sick freak but I
got to tell you in the last movie they
did this tribute to Paul Walker at the
end and oh my god everybody in the
theater was crying like a little [ __ ]
not me though I'm not that sensitive I
took it like a man I'm popular I'm good
man I'm sweating like a [ __ ] man
come home up why the day I want to dad
walked it down hey baby
like J Browne you don't have friends you
have family